this is the city of Wuhan it is home to
an estimated 11 million people in
eastern China it is here where health
officials believe the new coronavirus
originated and eventually spread across
the globe
cases of the disease it causes known as
kovat 19 have risen rapidly as health
officials have worked to contain the
virus here's how kovat 19 became a
global pandemic on December 1st 2019 a
patient in Wuhan begins to show symptoms
of viral pneumonia according to a report
in The Lancet medical journal that
patient is believed to be the first
documented case of the virus throughout
the month a series of pneumonia cases of
unknown cause emerge in Wuhan symptoms
include a fever labored breathing and a
dry cough at the end of the month the
Chinese government informs the World
Health Organization of a cluster of
pneumonia cases in cuon between December
31st and January 3rd a total of 44 cases
are reported to the WHL many of the
patients were found to have visited an
open-air seafood and animal market
within the city Chinese authorities shut
down the market and on January 5th the
w-h-o reports the infection could be
connected to exposure to live animals
Chinese scientists discover sick
patients are infected with a new strain
of corona virus according to chinese
state media corona viruses are a large
family of viruses that include the
common cold at this point there are no
documented instances of human-to-human
transmission On January 11th China
reports the first death from the disease
in Wuhan concerns grow about the ability
to contain the virus over the upcoming
Chinese Lunar New Year when millions of
people travel across the country
Wuhan is connected to other major
Chinese cities by nearly 22,000 miles of
high-speed rail and connected to the
world via an international airport that
transports 24 and a half million
passengers a year and connects to 30
cities around the globe
a Chinese tourists traveling from the
Wuhan area is found to have a fever
after arriving at the airport in Bangkok
Thailand on January 13th this person is
confirmed to have the first case of the
new corona virus outside of mainland
China over the next week cases appear
across Asia and in the United States as
well
according to the w-h-o On January 23rd
there are 581 confirmed cases globally
as health officials announced the virus
can spread between humans the Chinese
government cut strain and air travel out
of Wuhan effectively quarantine the
entire city in an effort to contain the
spread with over 7800 confirmed cases
the w-h-o declares the corona virus a
global public health emergency
indicating authorities believe the virus
is a significant threat beyond China in
Yokohama Japan passengers aboard the
diamond Princess cruise liner are
quarantined for almost three weeks
passengers are confined to the ship as
they are tested for the virus 696 people
on the ship are ultimately confirmed to
be infected including some Americans a
week later the w-h-o officially names
the disease kovat 19 the name is an
abbreviated form of corona virus disease
2019
on february 17th the number of new cases
reported by the w-h-o rises sharply
after Chinese authorities change the
criteria for diagnosing the illness
raising concerns that the virus is
speeding up not slowing down up until
this point the vast majority of cases
have been confined to mainland China but
by February 24th new cases flare in
South Korea Italy and Iran in the United
States thousands of people are asked to
self quarantine to curtail infections in
several states state health officials in
California Oregon and Washington report
new cases of kovat 19 with no travel
history to China or known exposure to
carry
worries increase that the virus is
spreading in American communities the
number of confirmed coronavirus cases
globally tops 100,000 as president Trump
signs into law at eight point three
billion dollar spending bill to combat
the virus over the next week and a half
major sporting events are canceled
schools and businesses are closed and
many Americans are advised to stay home
to limit contact with others on March
13th the president declares a national
emergency as the virus continues to
create major disruptions to American
life kovat 19 continues to spread and
impact communities around the globe as
health officials monitor the disease and
try to find ways to curtail it